Ти вже не згинеш Ти двожилова земля
грабована віками і не скарадь тебе
душителям сибірами та соловками і
медведчуками пророчі слова Василя Стуса
не Тиждень тому ми мали святкувати його
85-річчя стоячи йому тут аплодувати але
не зможемо його вбила Москва руками
своїх покидьків один з них Медведчук а
далі Медведчук перетворився на ракову
пухлину яка десятиліття Ми нищилась цю
країну нищила її і зараз ми видаляємо цю
пухлину з Верховної Ради чи це добре так
чи Цього досить Ні тому що метастази
цієї пухлини тут Тому що далі опзж в
Верховній Раді тих хто з ним їздив в
Москву хто виходив на балкон держдури
Російської Федерації ті хто їхав до
Путіна і лизав його чоботи вони надалі
тут їх треба Агент звідси викинути
чи цього достатньо Ні тому що далі має
бути трибунал а зрадники мають молитися
щоб дожити до цього трибуналу і я хочу
сказати всі п'яті колонії всім зрадникам
де вони зараз не були Москва Монако Київ
неважливо ви будете всі відповідати Всі
ви байстрюки катіфа сатанілих не
забувайте виродки ніде народ мій і є в
його козацьких жилах гаряча кров пульсує
і гуде Слава Україні